the three basic types of motion are  linear rotatory and circular linear  motion is divided into two types  rectilinear is when the object is moving  in a straight line for instance a car  moving in a straight line and curvy  linear is when the motion is curved an  example is a stone thrown into the air  at an angle rotatory motion is the  motion that occurs when the object is  rotating around its own axis the motion  of the earth about its own axis or the  motion of the wheels about its own axis  are examples of rotatory motion circular  motion is the motion of an object in a  circular path or we can say along the  circumference of a circle an example is  a stone tied to a string and swung in  circles what is oscillatory motion then  share your answers and do share this  video with your friends and family  [Music]